The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
Hi.
Our lesson today is
concerned with introducing
a new type of integral
when we deal with calculus
of several variables.
And this might at
first glance seem
to be a rather touchy
subject, the idea
being that up until
now, we've talked
about multiple
integration, yet you'll
notice that the title of
this block of material
is just called integration.
And the reason for
this is that when
we deal with several
variables, there
is more than one
type of integral,
and what I would like to
do is to motivate today's
lesson in terms of
a physical example
and then come back and talk
about, in more detail, what
happened, and why there is
more than one type of integral
in the calculus of
several variables.
I called today's lesson
Introduction to Line Integrals,
and to visualize how this
topic may be introduced,
consider the
following situation.
I have a force F, say, defined
throughout the xy-plane here.
I have two fixed points,
which I'll call P_0 and P_1,
and I pick a particular
curve which joins P_0 to P_1.
And the question that
I would like to solve
is what is the
work done if I move
a particle from P_0 to
P_1, along the curve C,
by means of the force f?
And the reason that this
is called a line integral
is that somehow
or other, you see,
I am going to be
dealing with the line
or the curve C. Let me assume,
for the sake of argument,
that I know the equation
of C in parametric form.
Let's assume simply
that C is given
by x as some function of t
and y as some function of t,
and since I'm going
from P_0 to P_1,
t is defined on a
specific closed interval.
Say t goes from t_0 to t_1.
Or, if I want to write the
equation of C in vector
form, remember, in
vector form, the i
component is x-- or at least
in Cartesian coordinate vector
form, the i component is
x, the j component is y.
So I can write
the same equation,
that the curve is R of t, where
R is x of t i plus y of t j.
As long as I'm using
Cartesian coordinates here,
let me assume that my force
is also given specifically
in terms of Cartesian
coordinates.
It's M*i plus N*j, where M and
N are specific functions of x
and y.
And just to review,
briefly, the problem,
I want to find the work done in
moving from P_0 to P_1 along C
under the influence of F.
Now you see, the
thing is we already
know how to solve work problems
if the distance takes place
along-- if the
displacement takes
place along a straight line.
So what we do is the following.
We take the curve C, and we
subdivide it into increments.
We break the thing up.
What we do is we look
at the k-th increment
and join the two endpoints
of that increment
by a straight line, a vector
which we'll call delta R sub k.
We pick a point on the
curve in this interval
and compute the F. After
all, we know the force
as a function of x and y,
but we compute that force
for that fixed point.
We then dot that force with this
displacement, and that is what?
That's the work that's done
if the particle had moved
along the straight line
connecting these two
points under the constant force
f of x of k star comma y sub k
star.
And then what we do is,
to find the approximation,
we add up all of
these forces, all
of these works over
the various increments.
Notice that you're doing two
things in these increments.
You're first of all picking
small enough segments
so that you can assume that the
straight line approximation is
a good approximation
to the curve.
And secondly, small
enough segments
so that you're assuming that
the force at a given point
is a good approximation
to the force
along the entire increment.
At any rate, what
we then do is we
sum these up over
all the increments.
And by the way, notice
that, even though f
is a function of x and
y, along the curve C,
x and y are functions of t.
And to emphasize this,
let me rewrite this simply
by dividing and multiplying
by delta t sub k
to indicate that if I
now put this remaining
part of the expression
in braces, what's in here
is really some
function of t alone.
In other words,
notice that this comes
very close to
being how we define
the ordinary definite integral
when we want to add things up.
You see, t is a scalar, and
that the braced expression here
is a function of t alone.
It's a dot product
obtained this way.
At any rate, what
we're saying now,
quite simply from the
physical point of view,
is define the actual work.
Why don't we define the work to
simply be the limit of w sub n
as the maximum delta R sub
k approaches zero, which
is equivalent to saying what?
Find this limit
as delta t sub k,
the maximum delta t
sub k approaches zero.
And the point is that this was
the ordinary definite integral.
Remember how we wrote this.
You replace the sum
by the integral sign.
We assume that t goes from
some value t_0 to t_1,
those become our
limits of integration.
Every place we see
the t sub k star,
we replace it simply
by t, and every place
we see the deltas we replace
those by d's and we leave off
the subscripts.
So, and I can't emphasize
this part strongly enough,
in going from here to here,
we are using nothing more
than what happened in
part one of our course.
Namely, this is the definition
of the definite integral
that we arrive at
this expression here.
And to show you other ways
in which this is written,
notice that F is M*i plus N*j.
R is x*i plus y*j, so dR/dt
is dx/dt i plus dy/dt j.
And so, if we then mechanically
just took the dot product here,
notice that the integrand would
be M*dx/dt plus N*dy/dt times
dt.
The conventional shortcut for
writing this is to cancel dt
from numerator and denominator,
and this becomes the standard
notation for the line integral
M*dx plus N*dy along the curve
C, where C joins P_0 to P_1.
And as I'll mention
in a few minutes,
it's crucial that we
specify both the curve
and the points being joined.
And the physicist
usually abbreviates this
by coming back to the
original notation here,
and when he takes the limit, he
just writes this as F dot dR.
And what I'm saying is that
this, this, and this are simply
different ways of writing
this expression here.
OK.
So this is how this
is then evaluated,
and what I'm going
to do very shortly
is specifically solve problems
using concrete values for F
and P_0 and P_1, but
for the time being,
I would like to make
a little note here,
to have you see
what's happening,
and that's the following.
Notice that double integrals
are concerned with regions.
In other words, we
use double integrals
to find area, mass, et cetera.
Line integrals are concerned
with curves or boundaries
of regions.
In other words, paths
that connect two points.
See, in other words,
somehow or other,
the double integral is
associated with area,
the line integral with length.
And the point is that in
one-dimensional space,
the two concepts coincide.
In fact, we don't even talk
about area in one dimension,
unless by area we meant
one-dimensional area or length.
In other words, both
arclength and area
in the typical
definition sense of area,
the one-dimensional
area, coincide
in one-dimensional space.
In two-dimensional space,
they are quite different.
In fact, in a nutshell,
to see what's happening,
essentially double
integrals are concerned
with what's going on
inside a region R,
whereas the line integral
somehow or other is concerned
with what's happening
as you move along
the boundary of the
region R, and we'll
talk about that in more
detail later in this lecture,
and this will also be
the topic of discussion
in our next lecture.
But essentially, for the
remainder of this lesson,
let's take a specific
application of our earlier
physical remarks.
In the following examples,
let's fix the points P_0
and P_1 to be the points (0,
0) and (1, 1), respectively.
And let the force M*i plus N*j
be specifically y squared i
plus x squared j.
In other words, to compute
the force at any point x comma
y in the plane, the i
component of the force
is just the square
of the y-coordinate,
the j component
is just the square
of the x-coordinate of
the point at which we're
computing the force.
Now, what we're going to do
in the next three examples
is simply compute the work done
along three different curves
that joined the point P_0
to P_1 and the work done
as a particle moves
from P_0 to P_1
under the influence of this
specific force, and as I say,
just the curve that joined
P_0 and P_1 will be different.
In the first example,
the curve C_1
is simply the straight line
that joins (0, 0) to (1, 1).
In parametric
form, that would be
x equals y equals t where t
goes from 0 to 1-- noticing
that when t is 0, you
see, x and y are both 0
so we're at the point
(0, 0), and when t is 1,
x and y are both 1, so
we're at the point (1, 1).
And if we want to write
that in vector form,
remembering that the i component
is just x and the j component
y, since x and y are both t, the
curve has the form r equals t*i
plus t*j.
The work done, writing
it symbolically
as we would, in the physical
notation, integral along c_1 F
dot dR means what?
We dot F with dR/dt,
and multiply that by dt
and integrate that from 0 to 1.
That's what that
infinite sum means.
Notice, in this
particular case, F,
which is y squared
plus x squared,
since x and y are
both equal to t,
F is just t squared
i plus t squared j.
Since R is t*i plus t*j,
dR/dt is just i plus j,
and consequently, the infinite
sum that we want to evaluate is
just the integral
from 0 to 1-- see,
just taking the
dot product here;
t squared plus t
squared is 2t squared--
integral from zero to
one, 2 t squared dt,
and using the fundamental
theorem of integral calculus
for a single variable, this is
simply evaluated by this being
t cubed from 0 to 1--
2/3 t cubed from 0 to 1,
this is just 2/3.
In other words, you
see what's hidden here
is the fact that, when we
write the definite integral--
see, this was a function
of two variables in here,
but along the curve, they have
functions just of the parameter
t.
This is an ordinary
integrand, which
means we can either think
of it as an infinite sum
or the antiderivative
evaluated in a specific way.
Don't lose track of the
fact that the work is still
being defined as a limit,
but we can compute it
quite conveniently in terms
of the fundamental theorem
of integral calculus.
At any rate, the
work done, then,
in example one as we move from
P_0 to P_1, under the force F,
along this curve
C_1 is just 2/3.
Now what we're going to do is
redo the same problem, only
now we are going to choose a
different path which connects
(0, 0) to (1, 1).
In fact, I will choose the
parabola y equals x squared,
and I'll write it
parametrically this way.
I'll let x equal
t, y be t squared.
So that says y equals x squared.
And to get to point
(0, 0), t must be 1.
To get to point (1,
1), t must be 1.
So again, t varies from
0 to 1 continuously,
or again in vector form, the
equation of the curve C_2 is
just what? t*i plus t squared j.
At any rate, the work done,
by definition, symbolically,
is the line integral
along C_2 F dot dR--
that still means f dot dR/dt
dt-- as t goes from 0 to 1.
In this case, x is t
and y is t squared.
So if we come back to
our definition of F
and replace x by t
and y by t squared,
we see that our force is t to
the 1/4 i plus t squared j.
Since R is t*i plus t squared
j, dR/dt is just i plus 2t*j.
Remember, we differentiate
vectors component by component.
Therefore, the
integrand is simply
this dot product, which
turns out to be, what?
t to the fourth times 1
plus t squared times 2t,
or t to the fourth
plus 2 t cubed.
We now, again, use the
fundamental theorem,
evaluate this integral
by the antiderivative.
In other words, this is 1/5
t to the fifth plus 1/2 t
to the fourth, evaluated
between 0 and 1,
and that answer is 7/10.
In fact, this, I
guess, in a way,
was a bad problem from a
physical point of view.
An excellent problem from a
mathematical point of view.
You see, certainly, from
a physical point of view,
7/10 looks enough like 2/3, so
the change isn't that drastic.
You can almost call that
an experimental error.
But since we weren't
doing an experiment here
and we're working
with exact numbers,
the fact does remain that, what?
2/3 and 7/10 are different,
and if nothing else, what we've
proven is what?
That the work done as we
move from two fixed points--
from the fixed point P_0
to the fixed point P_1,
under the influence
of a given force F,
actually does depend on
the path that we follow.
You see, we used
two different paths,
and got two different answers.
In other words, the line
integral M*dx plus N*dy along
the curve C, which joins two
fixed points P_0 and P_1,
depends on C as well
as on P_0 and P_1,
and that's an important
point to keep track of.
We're going to mention
this in more detail
as the course goes along.
At any rate though,
let that point
remain fixed in
abeyance for a while,
and we'll go on with
our next example.
And for the next example,
what I'm going to do
is pick the same path
as an example two,
only in a different
parametric form.
Another way of writing the
parabola y equals x squared
is to let x equal t squared
and y be t the fourth.
You see, in that case, y is
still equal to x squared,
and to connect (0, 0) to (1,
1), t still goes from 0 to 1.
So the work done
along the curve C_3
is given by this
particular symbol.
To evaluate this, remember
now, x is t squared.
So x squared will
be t to the fourth.
y is t to the
fourth, so y squared
would be t to the eighth.
Remembering that our
force is y squared i
plus x squared j, written
in two-tuple notation,
our force is t to the eighth
comma t to the fourth.
Our dR/dt vector is what?
It has components
2t and 4, t cubed,
and we're going to
multiply that by dt
and integrate that from 0 to 1.
That's simply 2 t to the ninth
plus 4 t to the seventh dt,
from 0 to 1.
That's t to the 10 over 5
plus t to the eighth over 2,
evaluated between
0 and 1, and that's
equal to 7/10, which
agrees with this result.
By the way, that's not a proof.
All I've shown is that
two parametric forms
led to the same amount of work.
But at any rate, it
does seem to indicate
that when you can compute
the work along the curve C,
that that work done seems to
be independent of the equation
for C.
And hopefully this
should be the case,
because we would be
in terrible trouble,
I guess is the best
word to put this as,
if it turned out that the
work done in moving along
a specific curve joining two
points under a specific force
depended on the equation
by which you represented
the curve.
But I simply wanted
to give you an example
to show at least that the
mathematical definition appears
to be consistent.
In other words,
along the curve C_1,
we got a different
amount of work done then
along the curves C_2 or C_3.
But C_2 and C_3
were actually what?
The same curve given by
two different equations.
So at any rate, the work does
seem to depend on the curve,
but it seems to be independent
of the equation by which
the curve is represented.
I think we're in position now
to start an overall summary,
going right back to the very
crux of the problem as to why
line integrals and
multiple integrals exist.
Namely, in particular,
in the case
of one independent variable, the
integral from a to b f of x dx
has two equivalent
interpretations.
And by equivalent, I mean
numerically equivalent.
You get the same answer.
They are not equivalent
philosophically.
You know, this is
one of the reasons
I have this hangup about
trying to spell out
the philosophy for you.
In many cases, you
will say, we're
interested more in the
application than in the theory.
As I may have said
to you before,
in fact on many
different occasions,
the easy part of
mathematics in most cases
is actually applying the
computational recipes.
The validity of the
recipes is what is usually
the difficult thing,
and the biggest mistakes
are not made by a person
using the right formula
and making an
arithmetic mistake.
It's that he uses
the wrong formula
and doesn't make an
arithmetic mistake.
So I want this to be
very clear to you,
why a certain problem
exists in two variables that
didn't exist in one.
And the point is, what?
That conceptually, there
were two different ways
to interpret the meaning
of the symbol integral
from a to b f of x dx.
Numerically, they came
out to be the same,
but what were the two
different interpretations?
One was as the limit of a
particular infinite sum.
That was the definite
integral notation.
The other was, we could
visualize the interval from a
to b as being a curve that could
be written parametrically, say,
as x is some function of t
where t goes from t_0 to t_1,
and we then make the
usual change of variables.
The same change of variables
that we were talking
about in the previous lecture.
Namely, every place we see
x, we replace it by x of t,
and then the correction
factor is dx/dt,
and the new limits
are from t_0 to t_1.
In other words, we get what?
That the integral
from a to b f of x dx
is the integral from t_0 to
t_1 f of x of t dx/dt times dt.
Again, observing that this
is a bona fide function of t
alone here, so this is just a
change of variable type thing.
And what am I saying?
That in the
one-dimensional case,
the case of one independent
variable, these two concepts,
while different, give rise
to the same numerical answer.
In two-space, however, notice
that our first interpretation
as an infinite sum translates
into the double or multiple
integral.
I keep saying double
because we're dealing
with two independent variables.
Obviously by now, I
hope it's clear to you
that the results
generalize to n variables.
But the idea is, what?
That the first interpretation
of the integral in terms
of two independent
variables gives
rise to the multiple integral.
In fact, I think I have
the-- Yeah, that's right.
And the second interpretation
gives rise to this expression
here.
Noticing again that if you
have a one-dimensional vector,
the dot product is
the ordinary product.
In other words, f of
x dx is f of x dot
dx, if you want to think of x as
being a one-dimensional vector.
But why is this interpretation?
Notice the change
of variables again,
that we think of the curve C as
being given by the equation R
equals some function of t
as t goes from t_0 to t_1.
So the substitution is what?
This means the particular
definite integral,
in terms of t, as t goes
from t_0 to t_1, f of R of t
dotted with dR/dt,
that again is what?
That again is some scalar
function of t, you see?
Times dt.
That's what that second
interpretation says,
and that's of
course what we mean
by this particular notation.
Two entirely different things.
But at any rate now,
getting back to what we saw
in our examples, the line
integral C f of R dot dR often
depends on x, but not on the
equation which represents C.
By the way, we're going to
show a very interesting thing
in the next lecture, as to when
the line integral will depend
on C and when it won't.
But the next
lecture, actually, is
more general than just
answering that question.
The next lecture centers
around this question.
Is there any
interesting relationship
between line integrals
and double integrals?
You see, in the case of
one independent variable,
there was a very
interesting relationship
between line integrals and
so-called double integrals
or integrals of infinite sums.
Namely, they were
exactly the same thing.
You couldn't tell them apart.
That's what we
meant in our summary
when we said we had two
different interpretations
of the same
numerical result. Now
the question is, in two
independent variables,
these two concepts
are different.
Are they related,
and if so, how?
And that will be the
body of our next lecture.
At any rate then, until
next time, goodbye.
Funding for the
publication of this video
was provided by the Gabriella
and Paul Rosenbaum Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.